- Selamat datang di Understanding
Quantum Information and Computation.
Nama saya John Watrous, dan saya adalah direktur teknis
dari IBM Quantum Education.
Tujuan dari seri ini adalah memberikan kamu
pemahaman yang solid tentang informasi dan komputasi kuantum, dan itu berarti kita akan masuk
ke detail teknisnya
dari informasi kuantum dan melihat bagaimana quantum
computing benar-benar bekerja, apa yang bisa dan tidak bisa dilakukan.
Kalau kamu belum menonton
video overview untuk seri ini, saya sarankan kamu untuk cek dulu.
Di video itu, kamu akan menemukan informasi tentang latar belakang
apa yang direkomendasikan untuk seri ini, beserta garis besar
topik yang akan dibahas.
Juga, pastikan kamu cek
Qiskit textbook, yang membahas materi yang sama seperti seri video ini dalam bentuk tulisan,
dan di sana juga ada
komponen interaktif dan antarmuka ke hardware dan software yang dirancang untuk membantu kamu lebih memahami
informasi dan komputasi kuantum. Kamu akan menemukan link ke video overview dan Qiskit textbook
di deskripsi.
Ini adalah pelajaran satu dari
unit satu dari seri ini.
Unit satu membahas dasar-dasar
informasi kuantum, dan di pelajaran pertama unit ini, kita akan fokus pada bagaimana
informasi kuantum bekerja
untuk sistem tunggal, artinya kita punya
hanya satu sistem fisik atau sebuah perangkat yang
menyimpan informasi kuantum
dan kita mempertimbangkan bagaimana
satu sistem atau perangkat itu bekerja secara terisolasi.
Di pelajaran berikutnya, kita akan membahas bagaimana
informasi kuantum bekerja ketika kita punya beberapa sistem dan itu akan memungkinkan kita
untuk mendeskripsikan konsep-konsep
yang menarik dan penting seperti algoritma kuantum yang menggunakan beberapa qubit
dan protokol kuantum
yang melibatkan beberapa individu yang memproses informasi kuantum dan saling mengirimnya
satu sama lain.
Tapi sebelum masuk ke diskusi itu, masuk akal untuk mulai dari
pengaturan yang relatif sederhana dari satu sistem secara terisolasi,
sebagian karena memang bagus untuk mulai dari yang sederhana, tapi juga karena seperti yang akan kita lihat, deskripsi tentang bagaimana
informasi kuantum bekerja
untuk sistem tunggal secara terisolasi mengarah sangat alami dan logis ke deskripsi tentang bagaimana
untuk beberapa sistem.
Berikut ini adalah gambaran singkat dari pelajaran ini.
Kita akan mulai dengan membahas
informasi klasik.
Sekarang, tujuan pelajaran ini bukan untuk menjelaskan bagaimana
informasi klasik bekerja, tapi untuk menjelaskan bagaimana
informasi kuantum bekerja,
tapi untuk menjelaskan bagaimana
informasi kuantum bekerja, sangat membantu untuk mulai
dengan informasi klasik dan menggunakannya sebagai
titik referensi yang familiar
saat kita membahas informasi kuantum.
Pada level matematis, informasi kuantum dan klasik sebenarnya punya deskripsi yang cukup mirip dengan beberapa perbedaan kunci, tentu saja.
Bahkan, informasi kuantum
sebenarnya tidak terpisah dari informasi klasik sama sekali.
Ini adalah perluasan dari
informasi klasik.
Faktanya,
setidaknya menurut saya, kamu benar-benar tidak bisa
memahami informasi kuantum kalau kamu tidak memahami
informasi klasik,
jadi memulai dengan informasi klasik
itu masuk akal.
Saya memang berharap bahwa konten ini
akan familiar bagi sebagian penonton, tapi meskipun kamu sudah familiar, saya tidak menyarankan kamu untuk melewatinya.
Selain menyoroti aspek-aspek informasi klasik yang paling relevan untuk
memahami informasi kuantum, kita juga akan memperkenalkan
notasi Dirac di bagian ini,
yang merupakan cara standar
yang akan kita gunakan untuk mendeskripsikan vektor dan
matriks sepanjang seri ini.
Ternyata, notasi Dirac itu
tidak spesifik untuk informasi kuantum.
Notasi ini sama-sama bisa digunakan dalam konteks informasi klasik maupun banyak pengaturan lain di mana vektor dan matriks muncul.
Kemudian kita akan beralih ke informasi kuantum, dan secara khusus, kita akan
membahas representasi keadaan kuantum sebagai vektor,
jenis pengukuran sederhana yang disebut pengukuran basis standar, dan operasi uniter, yang mendeskripsikan perubahan waktu diskret
dalam sistem kuantum.
Lagi-lagi, semuanya dalam pengaturan
sistem tunggal.
Sebelum kita mulai dengan pelajaran itu sendiri, akan sangat membantu untuk memperjelas bahwa sebenarnya ada dua deskripsi
tentang informasi kuantum, deskripsi yang disederhanakan, yang akan menjadi fokus kita di pelajaran ini
dan sepanjang unit pertama ini, dan deskripsi umum, yang dibahas di unit berikutnya, tepatnya di
unit ketiga dari seri ini.
Deskripsi yang disederhanakan,
sesuai namanya, lebih sederhana dan biasanya
dipelajari lebih dulu.
Dalam deskripsi yang disederhanakan, seperti yang sudah saya singgung, keadaan kuantum direpresentasikan oleh vektor dan operasi direpresentasikan
oleh matriks uniter.
Deskripsi informasi kuantum
ini sudah cukup untuk memahami
sebagian besar algoritma kuantum, misalnya,
jadi ini bukan oversimplified, ini yang sesungguhnya.
Namun, seperti yang akan kita
temukan seiring berjalannya waktu, deskripsi ini memang punya beberapa keterbatasan.
Misalnya, kalau kita mau
memodelkan efek noise pada sistem kuantum, deskripsi ini ternyata kurang memadai.
WEBVTT
Deskripsi umum, di sisi
lain, lebih umum dan pada akhirnya, lebih
powerful secara matematis.
Dalam deskripsi ini, keadaan kuantum direpresentasikan oleh kelas matriks khusus
yang disebut matriks densitas,
dan kelas pengukuran dan operasi yang lebih umum dapat dideskripsikan termasuk
noise, misalnya.
Ini sepenuhnya konsisten dengan
deskripsi yang disederhanakan dan bahkan, kamu bisa melihat
deskripsi yang disederhanakan
sebagai kasus khusus dari
deskripsi umum, dan deskripsi ini juga mencakup informasi klasik sebagai kasus khusus.
Ini juga benar-benar
indah dalam cara kerjanya, jadi saya sangat mendorong kamu untuk mempelajari deskripsi umum ini
ketika waktunya tepat, tapi deskripsi yang disederhanakan adalah tempat yang lebih alami untuk mulai, dan itulah yang akan kita lakukan.
Kita akan mulai dengan membahas informasi klasik dengan memperhatikan aspek-aspek
informasi klasik yang paling relevan
dengan informasi kuantum
dan cara deskripsinya
secara matematis.
Bayangkan kita punya sebuah
sistem fisik atau perangkat tertentu yang menyimpan informasi.
Kita akan memberi nama sistem ini X, tapi tidak ada
yang istimewa dari nama ini.
Kita bisa menggunakan nama lain
kalau kita mau, tapi supaya ada nama yang dipilih,
kita akan menyebut sistem ini X.
Kita akan membuat asumsi tentang X, yaitu bahwa ada
himpunan terbatas dari keadaan klasik yang mungkin dimiliki X pada saat tertentu.
Di sini, ketika saya menyebut keadaan klasik, saya maksudkan konfigurasi sistem yang bisa dikenali dan
dideskripsikan secara tidak ambigu
tanpa ketidakpastian atau kesalahan apapun.
Ini benar-benar sesuatu yang bisa kamu pikirkan secara intuitif. Pada level matematis, kita cukup mendefinisikan
himpunan keadaan klasik,
kita memilihnya sesuka kita atau dengan cara apa pun yang paling baik
mendeskripsikan perangkat yang kita kerjakan.
Mari kita beri nama sigma untuk
himpunan keadaan klasik ini, dan sekali lagi, saya ingin menekankan
bahwa kita mengasumsikan sigma adalah himpunan terbatas.
Himpunan keadaan klasik
dari sistem X ini tidak tak terbatas besar seperti
himpunan semua bilangan asli.
Ini terbatas, dan itu hanya
asumsi yang kita buat.
Misalnya, bisa jadi X adalah sebuah bit, di mana himpunan keadaan klasiknya adalah himpunan yang berisi dua
elemen: nol dan satu.
Kadang kita menyebut himpunan ini
sebagai alfabet biner.
Contoh lain adalah X merupakan
dadu enam sisi biasa, di mana keadaan klasiknya adalah angka satu sampai enam.
Tentu saja, kita sedang bicara
tentang abstraksi di sini.
Dadu enam sisi yang nyata mungkin
punya banyak atribut berbeda seperti posisi pastinya, orientasinya,
suhunya, dan sebagainya. Tapi dalam kaitannya dengan informasi yang paling sering relevan saat kita berbicara tentang dadu enam sisi,
keadaan klasiknya adalah
angka satu sampai enam yang ditunjukkan oleh jumlah titik di sisi dadu yang menghadap ke atas.
Kalau X adalah saklar pada
kipas angin biasa yang mungkin kamu punya di rumah, maka mungkin keadaan klasiknya
adalah pengaturan tinggi,
sedang, rendah, dan mati.
Ini hanya contoh-contoh saja. Kita bisa membayangkan sistem-sistem yang punya himpunan keadaan klasik yang berbeda dari ini, tapi semoga mereka menyampaikan ide
bahwa konsep keadaan klasik ini adalah sesuatu yang harusnya
familiar dan bisa dipahami dalam istilah yang sederhana dan intuitif.
Secara matematis, himpunan keadaan klasik
hanyalah himpunan terbatas, dan tentu saja, himpunan ini juga harus
tidak kosong.
Harus ada setidaknya
satu keadaan klasik yang bisa dimiliki sistem dan harus ada setidaknya dua keadaan klasik
kalau sistem itu berguna sama sekali untuk menyimpan informasi.
Sekarang, dalam beberapa situasi, kita mungkin tahu bahwa X ada
dalam suatu keadaan tertentu, tapi dalam banyak situasi,
yang muncul dalam konteks
pemrosesan informasi, mungkin ada ketidakpastian tentang keadaan klasik dari sebuah
sistem pada saat tertentu
sehingga setiap kemungkinan keadaan klasik punya probabilitas yang terkait dengannya.
Misalnya, kalau X adalah sebuah bit, mungkin kasusnya adalah X berada dalam keadaan klasik nol
dengan probabilitas tiga perempat dan berada dalam keadaan satu
dengan probabilitas satu perempat.
Kita akan menyebut ini
sebagai keadaan probabilistik, dan kita bisa mengekspresikan
keadaan probabilistik ini, seperti yang kamu lihat di sini,
cukup dengan menunjukkan apa
probabilitasnya untuk keadaan klasik yang berbeda-beda.
Cara yang lebih ringkas untuk mengekspresikan
keadaan probabilistik ini adalah dengan sebuah vektor, khususnya representasi
yang kamu lihat di sini
adalah vektor kolom, dan vektor ini menunjukkan
apa probabilitasnya untuk dua kemungkinan keadaan klasik.
Lebih spesifik lagi, entri pertama menunjukkan
apa probabilitas untuk X berada dalam keadaan nol, dan entri kedua memberi tahu
kita apa probabilitasnya
untuk sistem berada dalam keadaan satu. Ini hanyalah cara alami untuk mengurutkan alfabet biner,
atau setidaknya, itulah cara yang
kita terlatih untuk melakukannya. Dengan nol di depan dan satu di belakang.
Ke depannya, kita akan menggunakan
istilah vektor probabilitas untuk menunjukkan vektor seperti ini.
WEBVTT
Khususnya, ini adalah vektor yang semua entri-nya adalah
bilangan real non-negatif dan di mana jumlah dari
entri-entri itu sama dengan satu,
jadi masuk akal untuk
menganggap entri-entri ini sebagai probabilitas.
Di contoh ini, hanya ada dua entri karena hanya ada dua
keadaan klasik dari sistem yang kita bicarakan,
tapi secara umum, bisa ada
jumlah entri berapa pun dengan pemahaman
bahwa ada satu entri untuk setiap keadaan klasik
dari sistem apa pun yang kita bicarakan.
Kita akan terus
membahas informasi klasik, vektor probabilitas dan
sebagainya sebentar lagi, tapi pertama-tama, akan sangat membantu
untuk memperkenalkan notasi
untuk mendeskripsikan vektor yang dikenal sebagai notasi Dirac.
Sebenarnya, ini hanyalah bagian pertama
dari notasi Dirac.
Ada beberapa
aspek lain dari notasi Dirac yang akan kita lihat sedikit
lebih jauh dalam pelajaran ini.
Notasi ini akan menjadi
sangat penting dalam cara kita mendeskripsikan informasi kuantum, jadi sangat penting untuk
memahami cara kerjanya,
tapi untungnya, sangat sederhana dan tidak ada hubungannya secara spesifik dengan informasi kuantum,
jadi kita bisa memperkenalkannya sekarang
dalam konteks informasi klasik yang sudah familiar.
Seperti sebelumnya, kita asumsikan bahwa kita punya himpunan sigma dari
keadaan klasik suatu sistem, dan kita asumsikan
bahwa kita punya urutan
dari keadaan klasik ini, sama seperti ketika kita menyebut urutan dari alfabet biner
di contoh sebelumnya. Cara lain untuk mengatakan ini
adalah bahwa elemen-elemen sigma ditempatkan dalam korespondensi
dengan bilangan bulat
dari satu hingga berapa pun banyaknya
elemen yang terkandung dalam sigma, yang merupakan arti dari notasi dengan dua garis di sekitar sigma ini.
Itulah jumlah
elemen dalam himpunan sigma.
Jadi ada keadaan pertama,
keadaan kedua, dan seterusnya.
Urutan atau
korespondensi spesifik yang kita pilih sebenarnya tidak terlalu penting.
Yang benar-benar penting adalah
bahwa kita punya urutan dan kita konsisten dengannya.
Untuk banyak himpunan keadaan klasik
yang akan kita temui, akan ada urutan standar sama seperti yang kita miliki dengan
alfabet biner,
dan kalau tidak ada urutan standar, kita bisa memilih satu.
Tapi apa pun itu, pemahaman-nya adalah bahwa kita konsisten dengannya.
Sekarang, inilah notasi
yang diperkenalkan.
Untuk pilihan keadaan klasik a
dari himpunan sigma kita, kita menulis ini, yang dibaca sebagai ket a
untuk menyatakan vektor kolom
yang punya satu di entri yang sesuai dengan a dan nol untuk semua entri lainnya.
Misalnya, kalau kita kembali
ke alfabet biner, yang, seperti yang mungkin kamu sudah duga, adalah contoh yang sangat penting
yang akan kita kembalikan lagi dan lagi. Kemudian ket nol dan ket satu adalah vektor-vektor yang didefinisikan di sini.
Ket nol adalah vektor
yang punya satu di entri yang sesuai dengan keadaan klasik nol, yang merupakan entri pertama,
dan nol untuk semua entri lainnya, dan dalam kasus ini, hanya ada
satu entri lainnya.
Demikian pula, ket satu adalah
vektor ini di mana kita punya satu di entri
yang sesuai dengan satu,
yang merupakan entri kedua, dan nol untuk semua entri lainnya, yang, sekali lagi, hanya satu entri.
Ini contoh lainnya. Dalam contoh ini, kita punya himpunan keadaan klasik sigma yang sesuai dengan empat jenis
dalam satu set kartu remi standar: clubs, diamonds, hearts, dan spades.
Dalam kasus ini, sebenarnya tidak ada
urutan yang disepakati secara universal untuk jenis-jenis ini.
Untuk banyak permainan kartu, tidak ada urutan sama sekali. Mereka hanya empat jenis berbeda dan itu saja yang penting, dan ada permainan kartu berbeda yang memang mengurutkan jenis-jenis ini
dengan cara yang berbeda, tapi itu tidak terlalu penting.
Kita bisa memilih
urutan seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Ini kebetulan adalah urutan alfabetis berdasarkan nama-nama empat jenis ini yang ditulis dalam bahasa Inggris,
Dengan asumsi bahwa kita sudah memilih
urutan khusus ini, maka kita mendefinisikan empat vektor ini: ket clubs, ket diamonds,
ket hearts, dan ket spades
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini, dan vektor-vektor ini sesuai
dengan deskripsi umum yang kamu lihat di atas.
Mengingat bahwa kita sudah memilih
urutan khusus ini untuk keempat jenis ini.
Kita bisa melakukan hal yang sama untuk himpunan keadaan klasik apa pun yang kita pilih.
Ingat bahwa himpunan keadaan klasik selalu berarti himpunan terbatas dan tidak kosong.
Vektor-vektor dengan bentuk ini
disebut vektor basis standar, dan merupakan fakta yang sangat mendasar tentang vektor bahwa setiap vektor bisa
diekspresikan dengan cara yang unik
sebagai kombinasi linear
dari vektor basis standar.
Misalnya, kembali ke contoh dari sebentar tadi, vektor probabilitas
yang kita lihat bisa diekspresikan
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini. Ini pada dasarnya hanya cara alternatif untuk mengekspresikan vektor
yang akan sangat berguna untuk beberapa alasan ke depannya.
WEBVTT
Dan dengan notasi itu sekarang sudah kita kuasai, mari kita kembali ke diskusi
tentang informasi klasik dan keadaan probabilistik, khususnya.
Dan mari kita pertimbangkan apa yang terjadi
ketika kita mengukur sebuah sistem saat berada dalam keadaan probabilistik tertentu.
Kita mungkin tidak biasanya
menyebut pengukuran atau tindakan mengukur
sesuatu dalam konteks klasik, tapi istilah itu masuk akal.
Intinya, ketika kita berbicara
tentang mengukur sistem X dalam konteks ini, kita hanya berarti bahwa kita melihatnya dan kita mengenali keadaan apa pun yang dimilikinya.
Tentu saja, ketika kita melihat sistem itu, kita tidak melihat keadaan probabilistik, kita melihat keadaan klasik,
dan keadaan klasik
tertentu yang kita lihat adalah keadaan yang bisa kita
bayangkan dipilih secara acak sesuai dengan probabilitas.
Sekarang, kamu mungkin keberatan dari
sudut pandang filosofis terhadap gagasan bahwa keadaan klasik yang kita lihat entah bagaimana dipilih secara acak
pada saat kita mengukur atau kita melihat sistem itu, sistem itu hanya berada dalam keadaan klasik
tertentu sepanjang waktu
dan kita kebetulan baru saja
mengetahui apa keadaannya, tapi demi memikirkan tentang kerangka matematis yang sedang kita kerjakan,
tidak apa-apa untuk memikirkannya dengan cara ini dan melakukan itu akan memungkinkan kita untuk menarik paralel dengan
informasi kuantum sedikit lebih lanjut.
Mari kita asumsikan bahwa
keadaan klasik yang kita lihat adalah keadaan klasik a, yang bisa berupa keadaan mana saja dalam himpunan sigma kita.
Ini mengubah keadaan probabilistik
dari X secara umum, setidaknya dari sudut pandang kita.
Probabilitas tidak lagi
punya signifikansi apa pun karena kita sekarang tahu apa
keadaan klasik dari X.
Keadaannya adalah a, dan tidak ada lagi
ketidakpastian tentang ini.
Jadi kita sekarang akan mengatakan bahwa probabilitas bahwa sistem berada dalam keadaan a adalah satu.
Kita tahu ini karena kita baru saja melihatnya dan kita melihat bahwa keadaan klasiknya adalah a, jadi keadaan probabilistik baru dari X adalah satu
di mana probabilitas
berada dalam keadaan klasik a sama dengan satu.
Dan keadaan probabilistik itu direpresentasikan oleh
vektor probabilitas ket a.
Kita punya satu di entri yang sesuai dengan keadaan klasik a dan nol di semua entri lainnya.
Misalnya, kalau kita lagi
mempertimbangkan situasi di mana X adalah sebuah bit dan kita punya keadaan
probabilistik yang sama seperti sebelumnya,
maka kalau kita mengukur X, kita bisa membayangkan bahwa
sebuah transisi terjadi.
Dengan probabilitas tiga perempat, kita melihat keadaan klasik nol, dan dengan melakukan pengukuran, kita beralih ke ket nol
sebagai keadaan probabilistik kita,
dan dengan probabilitas satu perempat, kita beralih ke ket satu.
Kamu bisa memikirkan ini sebagai transisi pengetahuan kalau kamu mau, berbeda dengan transisi
fisik yang sebenarnya,
tapi yang penting
untuk keperluan pelajaran ini adalah mengenali cara kerja matematikanya.
Ini sebenarnya sepele, tapi dengan mengenali kesederhanaan ini, deskripsi analognya
untuk setting kuantum
mungkin akan terasa sedikit lebih tidak misterius.
Satu catatan akhir adalah bahwa bagi orang lain yang kebetulan tidak melihat apa
keadaan klasik dari X saat kita mengukurnya,
keadaan probabilistik
tentu saja tidak akan berubah akibat kita telah mengukurnya.
Tidak apa-apa. Individu yang berbeda bisa
memiliki pengetahuan yang berbeda tentang sistem tertentu dan sesuai dengan itu memilih
keadaan probabilistik yang berbeda
untuk merepresentasikan
pengetahuan mereka tentang sistem tersebut.
Di bagian terakhir dari diskusi tentang informasi klasik ini, kita akan berbicara tentang operasi klasik yang bisa dilakukan pada sebuah sistem,
mulai dengan operasi deterministik.
Ketika kita melakukan operasi pada sebuah sistem, keadaannya umumnya berubah sebagai hasilnya, dan dalam konteks ini, kata deterministik berarti
bahwa hasil dari melakukan
operasi sepenuhnya bergantung pada keadaan klasik
sistem sebelumnya
sebelum operasi dilakukan.
Dengan kata lain, tidak ada
unsur kebetulan ketika operasi deterministik
dilakukan, jadi tidak ada keacakan
atau ketidakpastian yang terlibat.
Dalam istilah matematis, operasi deterministik
dideskripsikan oleh fungsi.
Setiap fungsi f dari bentuk
yang kamu lihat di sini, yang berarti bahwa baik input maupun output dari fungsi
sesuai dengan elemen dari
himpunan keadaan klasik sigma kita, mendeskripsikan operasi deterministik.
Keadaan klasik a
ditransformasi menjadi keadaan f dari a untuk setiap pilihan keadaan a.
Untuk setiap fungsi f dari bentuk ini, akan selalu ada matriks unik M yang memenuhi kondisi ini
yang kamu lihat di sini,
yaitu bahwa dengan mengalikan
M ke vektor ket a memberikan kita vektor ket f dari a,
dan itu berlaku untuk setiap
pilihan keadaan klasik a.
Tidak terlalu sulit untuk menulis
deskripsi eksplisit dari M berdasarkan fungsi f
dari bentuk ini yang sudah kita pilih.
Ini akan selalu punya tepat
satu, satu di setiap kolom dengan setiap entri lainnya sama dengan nol.
Dan inilah rumusnya. Entri b, a dari M sama dengan satu jika b sama dengan f dari a
dan kalau tidak, sama dengan nol, dan dengan ini, kita maksudkan
ini adalah entri dari M yang barisnya sesuai dengan b
dan kolomnya sesuai dengan a.
WEBVTT
Kita akan melihat beberapa contoh sebentar lagi, dan kita akan melihat mengapa rumus ini bekerja.
Sekarang, mungkin tidak jelas mengapa kita mau mengambil sebuah fungsi dan mengekspresikannya sebagai matriks seperti ini,
tapi memang masuk akal untuk melakukan ini. Salah satu alasannya, dan mungkin itu adalah alasan utamanya, adalah bahwa kalau kita punya sebuah sistem
dalam keadaan probabilistik
dan kita melakukan operasi deterministik
pada sistem itu, maka keadaan probabilistik
yang dihasilkan bisa diperoleh
dengan perkalian matriks-vektor, yaitu, kalau sistem kita ada
dalam keadaan probabilistik
yang direpresentasikan oleh
beberapa vektor probabilitas v dan kita melakukan operasi deterministik yang dideskripsikan oleh M
pada sistem itu, maka keadaan probabilistik yang dihasilkan akan diberikan oleh M kali v.
Di sini, omong-omong, panah dengan garis kecil di atasnya seperti ini hanyalah notasi umum dalam matematika untuk menunjukkan bagaimana satu
hal dipetakan ke
atau ditransformasi menjadi hal lain. Kamu bisa menggunakan panah biasa saja, tapi ini adalah konvensi
dan mudah dikenali dan mungkin sedikit lebih spesifik daripada hanya sebuah panah, yang bisa berarti banyak hal berbeda.
Sekarang mari kita lihat sebuah contoh atau kumpulan contoh, sebenarnya.
Mari kita pertimbangkan apa yang terjadi ketika kita mengambil himpunan keadaan klasik sigma kita menjadi sekali lagi alfabet biner.
Tidak terlalu banyak fungsi yang berbeda dari bentuk yang sudah kita bahas ketika ini adalah himpunan keadaan klasik kita dan untuk lebih tepatnya, hanya ada empat
fungsi dari bentuk ini.
Di sini, keempat fungsi itu dideskripsikan oleh tabel nilai-nilainya.
Tabel pertama mendeskripsikan
fungsi pertama, yang kita namakan f1.
Untuk setiap input yang mungkin di sebelah kiri, kita mencantumkan
output yang sesuai di sebelah kanan, jadi f1 dari nol sama dengan nol,
dan f1 dari satu, sekali lagi, sama dengan nol, yang berarti f1 adalah
fungsi konstan nol.
Selalu mengambil nilai nol.
Fungsi kedua f2
adalah fungsi identitas.
Output selalu sama dengan input seperti yang bisa kamu lihat dari tabel kedua.
Fungsi ketiga f3 dideskripsikan
oleh tabel ketiga.
f3 dari nol sama dengan satu, dan f3 dari satu sama dengan nol.
Fungsi ini lebih dikenal
sebagai fungsi not atau negasi logis.
Kita kadang juga menyebutnya bit flip karena ini membalik nol
ke satu dan satu ke nol.
Fungsi terakhir f4 adalah,
sekali lagi, fungsi konstan seperti yang pertama, tapi ini adalah fungsi konstan satu
karena selalu mengambil nilai satu.
Dan itulah hanya empat fungsi dari alfabet biner ke dirinya sendiri.
Berikut adalah empat matriks yang sesuai dengan keempat fungsi yang dideskripsikan oleh
rumus dari sebelumnya,
yang bisa kamu lihat di sini, dan kalau kamu mau, kamu bisa menjeda video dan memverifikasi ini.
Ingat saja bahwa dengan matriks, urutan indeks selalu baris dulu, kolom kedua.
Jadi entri b, a sesuai
dengan baris b dan kolom a atau baris yang sesuai
dengan keadaan klasik b
dan kolom yang sesuai
dengan keadaan klasik a.
Jadi misalnya, kalau kita lihat
fungsi pertama, kita punya f1 dari nol sama dengan nol
dan sebagai hasilnya, entri
nol, nol dari M1 sama dengan satu.
Nah, entri satu, nol
yang ada di sini sama dengan nol, dan kamu bisa melakukan hal yang sama untuk kasusnya
di mana inputnya sama dengan satu dan demikian pula, untuk
ketiga fungsi lainnya.
Kamu juga bisa memverifikasi bahwa rumus dari sebelumnya itu benar dan kamu bisa memeriksa satu per satu semua kemungkinan yang berbeda untuk memverifikasinya.
Dan bahkan, kalau kamu memikirkan cara
perkalian matriks bekerja, kamu sebenarnya bisa langsung melihatnya secara intuitif.
Ketika kamu mengalikan sebuah matriks ke vektor basis standar seperti ini, kamu bisa membayangkan bahwa
kamu mengambil input
dan memasukkannya ke
bagian atas salah satu matriks di kolom mana pun yang sesuai
dengan keadaan klasik
di dalam ket, dan output yang kamu
dapatkan hanyalah kolom itu sebagai vektor probabilitas.
Jadi misalnya, M3 dikalikan ke ket
nol memberikanmu nol, satu
sebagai vektor probabilitas, yaitu ket satu.
M3 dikalikan ke ket
satu memberikanmu satu, nol, yaitu ket nol dan seterusnya.
Kita akan membahas operasi pada
keadaan probabilistik lebih jauh sebentar lagi, tapi pertama-tama, mari kita perkenalkan bagian kedua dari notasi Dirac.
Ini akan membantu
untuk berbicara tentang operasi dan memikirkannya sebagai matriks, dan ini juga akan menjadi alat standar
yang akan kita terus gunakan ke depannya. Pengaturannya sama seperti sebelumnya.
Kita punya himpunan keadaan klasik sigma apa pun yang sedang kita kerjakan dan kita asumsikan bahwa kita punya cara untuk
mengurutkan keadaan klasik itu.
Kemudian kita menulis ini
yang kamu lihat di sini di mana kali ini garis miring ada di sebelah kiri bukan kanan untuk menyatakan
vektor baris yang punya satu
di entri yang
sesuai dengan a dan nol untuk semua entri lainnya yang sesuai dengan semua
keadaan klasik lainnya.
Jadi perbedaan antara
ini dan ket a adalah bahwa ini adalah vektor baris dan
ket a adalah vektor kolom,
WEBVTT
tapi selain itu, vektor-vektor
didefinisikan dengan cara yang sama.
Kita membaca ini sebagai bra a, saya tidak yakin apakah itu dimaksudkan lucu, tapi idenya adalah bahwa nama-nama bra dan ket
adalah dua bagian dari kata bracket, dan kita akan punya lebih banyak yang dikatakan
tentang itu sebentar lagi.
Tapi pertama-tama, mari kita lihat
sebuah contoh yang sangat singkat.
Untuk alfabet biner, kita punya bahwa bra nol adalah
vektor baris ini yang analogis dengan ket a,
kecuali ini adalah vektor baris
bukan vektor kolom dan bra satu adalah vektor ini.
Sekarang secara umum, kalau kita mengalikan vektor baris
ke vektor kolom, hanya dengan memikirkan ini sebagai matriks
yang kebetulan punya
hanya satu baris atau hanya satu kolom, maka kita mendapatkan matriks satu kali satu, yang bisa kita anggap
sebagai skalar.
Di sini, omong-omong, kamu harus
memikirkan bintang-bintang ini sebagai merepresentasikan bilangan sembarang.
Khususnya, kalau kita
mengalikan vektor baris bra a ke vektor kolom ket b,
maka ada dua hal yang bisa terjadi.
Satu adalah bahwa a dan b sama, jadi mereka adalah keadaan klasik yang sama, dalam hal ini, satu-satuannya akan sejajar
dan hasilnya akan sama dengan satu atau bisa juga kasusnya
a dan b berbeda,
sehingga satu-satuannya tidak sejajar dan hasilnya sama dengan nol.
Cara sederhana untuk mengekspresikan
pengamatan-pengamatan ini adalah seperti ini.
Dan hanya untuk menjaga kerapian, kita menulis produk ini seperti ini dengan hanya satu garis di tengah dan artinya persis sama
dengan ini.
Dan sekarang kamu bisa melihat bagaimana
bra dan ket bergabung untuk membentuk bracket, yang juga disebut inner product,
dan itu adalah sesuatu
yang cukup penting yang akan kita kembali ke
pelajaran nomor tiga.
Mengalikan vektor kolom
ke vektor baris, di sisi lain, memberikan kita matriks seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Jadi misalnya, kembali lagi
ke alfabet biner, kalau kita mengalikan ket nol ke bra nol,
yang kita dapatkan adalah matriks ini, dan kita bisa memeriksa
kemungkinan-kemungkinan lainnya untuk melihat apa yang terjadi.
Ket nol kali bra satu memberikan
kita matriks ini di mana satu sekarang sudah berpindah
ke posisi ini.
Ket satu, bra nol terlihat seperti ini dan inilah ket satu, bra satu.
Apa yang kita lihat terjadi adalah bahwa ada hanya satu angka satu dalam matriks yang selebihnya semua nol, dan posisi dari satu itu
ditentukan oleh keadaan klasik
yang kita pilih dalam bra dan ket.
Lebih tepatnya, dan
ini berlaku secara umum, untuk pilihan himpunan keadaan klasik apa pun, matriks yang kita dapatkan dengan
mengalikan ket a ke bra b
adalah matriks dengan satu di entri a, b dan nol untuk semua entri lainnya.
Dan sekarang bahwa kita sudah punya baik
bagian pertama maupun bagian kedua dari notasi Dirac, kita punya alat yang sangat berguna untuk menghubungkan operasi dengan matriks.
Jadi mari kita kembali sebentar
ke operasi deterministik dan ingat bahwa sedikit
sebelumnya dalam pelajaran,
dinyatakan bahwa untuk setiap fungsi f dari
bentuk ini, kita punya operasi deterministik yang mentransformasi a menjadi f dari a
untuk setiap kemungkinan keadaan klasik a. Dan kita mengatakan bahwa untuk
fungsi seperti ini, selalu ada matriks unik
M yang bertindak seperti ini
pada keadaan basis standar.
Menggunakan notasi Dirac, kita sekarang bisa sangat mudah mengekspresikan matriks ini seperti yang kamu lihat di sini,
dan kita bisa melihat bagaimana terkadang
sangat mungkin untuk bekerja dengan matriks sepenuhnya
dalam kerangka notasi Dirac
tanpa pernah secara eksplisit mengkonversi
ke vektor dan matriks, yaitu persegi panjang yang diisi dengan angka.
Dalam kasus ini, kita bisa memverifikasi bahwa
rumus yang diperlukan benar dengan mengalikan M ke ket a.
Kita mengganti
ekspresi kita untuk M seperti ini dan kita bisa menghapus tanda kurung dan menyatukan bra
b dengan ket a seperti ini.
Dan itu karena perkalian matriks
bersifat linear, dalam kasus ini, dalam argumen pertama dan bersifat asosiatif sehingga kita bisa menghapus tanda kurungnya.
Dan sekarang, mengingat bahwa kita punya a tetap yang sedang kita bicarakan saat kita menjumlahkan semua
kemungkinan pilihan b,
bracket ini selalu
akan sama dengan nol ketika b tidak sama dengan a, jadi tidak akan ada
kontribusi pada jumlah,
dan ketika b sama dengan a, bracket akan sama dengan satu dan sehingga kita akan mendapatkan
satu suku ini.
Itulah rumus yang kita inginkan dan jadi kita punya cara yang sangat bagus dan sederhana untuk mengekspresikan fungsi sebagai matriks.
Selain operasi deterministik, kita juga punya operasi yang
itu sendiri memperkenalkan keacakan atau ketidakpastian tentang
keadaan klasik sebuah sistem.
Kita menggunakan istilah operasi probabilistik untuk menyebut operasi seperti ini, dan untuk lebih tepatnya, ketika kita menyebut operasi probabilistik,
kita maksudkan operasi yang
mungkin memperkenalkan keacakan, jadi operasi deterministik sebenarnya adalah kasus khusus
dari operasi probabilistik
yang kebetulan tidak
memperkenalkan keacakan apapun.
Berikut ini contoh sederhana di mana
sedikit keacakan diperkenalkan.
Ini adalah operasi pada satu bit. Cara kerjanya adalah bahwa kalau keadaan klasik
dari bit adalah nol,
maka tidak ada yang terjadi. Bit tetap sebagai nol, tapi kalau keadaan klasik
dari bit adalah satu, maka operasi membalik bit ke nol
WEBVTT
dengan probabilitas sama dengan 1/2.
Tidak ada nama khusus
untuk operasi ini, setidaknya bukan yang saya tahu.
Ini hanya sebuah contoh, tapi kamu bisa membayangkan melakukan
operasi ini pada sebuah bit.
Sama seperti operasi deterministik, operasi probabilistik bisa
direpresentasikan oleh matriks dan aksinya pada keadaan probabilistik
diberikan oleh perkalian matriks-vektor seperti sebelumnya.
Kali ini, tidak harus begitu bahwa matriks punya tepat satu, satu di setiap kolom dan nol selainnya.
Operasi probabilistik secara
lebih umum direpresentasikan oleh matriks stokastik.
Ini adalah matriks yang entri-entri-nya semua
bilangan real non-negatif dan di mana entri-entri di
setiap kolom berjumlah satu.
Itu sama dengan mengatakan
bahwa matriks stokastik adalah matriks di mana setiap kolom
membentuk vektor probabilitas.
Itu masuk akal kalau kamu memikirkan
aksi dari sebuah matriks pada vektor basis standar.
Kamu mempertimbangkan keadaan klasik
apa pun yang kamu inginkan dan kamu membayangkan memasukkan keadaan itu ke bagian atas matriks di kolom mana pun yang sesuai
dengan keadaan klasik itu,
dan kolom itu memberitahumu apa
keadaan probabilistik yang keluar sebagai vektor probabilitas.
Operasi probabilistik
dalam contoh kita, misalnya, dideskripsikan oleh matriks ini.
Kalau kita melakukan operasi ini
pada keadaan klasik nol, maka keadaan probabilistik yang kita dapatkan diberikan oleh kolom pertama,
yang lagi-lagi, adalah keadaan klasik nol atau secara setara, keadaan probabilistik
di mana nol muncul dengan probabilitas satu.
Kalau sebaliknya, kita melakukan operasi ini pada keadaan klasik satu, maka kita secara efektif hanya mengacak bit dan sebagai hasilnya, kita mendapatkan
vektor probabilitas ini
di mana probabilitas untuk
setiap kemungkinan keadaan sama dengan 1/2.
Secara umum, kalau kita melakukan operasi ini pada keadaan probabilistik apa pun, maka efeknya pada dasarnya
hanyalah rata-rata berbobot antara dua kolom
karena itulah cara perkalian matriks-vektor
bekerja.
Ini linear, jadi kita hanya merata-rata dua
kemungkinan hasil sesuai dengan itu.
Ketika kita memikirkan operasi probabilistik
dengan cara ini, wajar untuk memikirkan
mereka sebagai berpotensi memperkenalkan atau menyuntikkan keacakan.
Kita bisa membaca kolom satu per satu dan kita bisa melihat keacakan
yang mereka perkenalkan untuk setiap keadaan klasik yang mungkin.
Kamu juga bisa memikirkan
operasi probabilistik dengan cara yang sedikit berbeda, yaitu bahwa mereka adalah pilihan acak dari operasi deterministik.
Misalnya, dalam contoh kita, kita bisa memikirkan operasi ini sebagai setara dengan
melempar koin yang adil
dan melakukan
fungsi konstan nol atau fungsi identitas
masing-masing dengan probabilitas 1/2,
dan kamu bisa melihat itu tercermin
di sini oleh persamaan ini.
Itu selalu mungkin untuk
operasi probabilistik mana pun, dan cukup intuitif.
Kalau kamu membuat pilihan acak
sebagai bagian dari suatu proses, kamu selalu bisa membayangkan membuat pilihan acak itu terlebih dahulu
dan kemudian hard-coding pilihan-pilihan
itu ke dalam beberapa kumpulan operasi deterministik.
Terkadang sangat membantu untuk memikirkan operasi probabilistik
dengan cara ini, dan kita akan melihat contoh
dari ini beberapa pelajaran ke depan.
Hal terakhir yang perlu dikatakan
tentang informasi klasik untuk pelajaran ini menyangkut komposisi
operasi probabilistik, yang hanya berarti melakukan
satu demi satu.
Mari kita asumsikan bahwa kita
punya beberapa sistem bernama X dan M1 sampai Mn adalah matriks stokastik yang merepresentasikan operasi probabilistik
pada X.
Bayangkan pertama kita punya
vektor probabilitas v, yang merepresentasikan keadaan probabilistik
dari X pada suatu saat, dan kemudian kita pertama menerapkan
operasi probabilistik pertama pada X, yang direpresentasikan oleh matriks M1, dan kemudian kita menerapkan operasi probabilistik kedua,
yang direpresentasikan oleh M2.
Kalau kita melakukan itu, maka
vektor probabilitas yang kita dapatkan setelah menerapkan hanya operasi pertama adalah M1 kali v,
dan kemudian ketika kita menerapkan
operasi kedua, vektor probabilitas yang dihasilkan adalah M2 dikalikan ke vektor apa pun yang kita peroleh
setelah menerapkan M1. Jadi terlihat seperti ini.
Sekarang, perkalian matriks
adalah operasi asosiatif, yang berarti tidak masalah di mana kita meletakkan tanda kurung ini.
Jadi kita bisa sama mudahnya
meletakkan tanda kurung seperti ini.
Itu sangat sederhana, tapi juga menarik karena mengungkapkan bahwa kita
bisa memikirkan operasi di mana kita pertama menerapkan M1
dan kemudian kita menerapkan M2
sebagai operasi tunggal.
Dengan kata lain, operasi
probabilistik yang kita dapatkan dengan mengomposisikan operasi probabilistik pertama dan
kedua direpresentasikan oleh produk matriks, M2 kali M1,
dan itu adalah operasi yang sama terlepas dari keadaan probabilistik
apa yang kita mulai.
Kita tidak perlu mengetahui apa pun tentang vektor probabilitas v untuk memikirkan atau mendeskripsikan
operasi yang dikomposisikan ini.
Perhatikan bahwa urutannya
adalah M2 di sebelah kiri dan M1 di sebelah kanan, yang karena
matriks di sebelah kanan, M1,
adalah yang dikalikan
ke vektor v, sedangkan M2 dikalikan
ke vektor apa pun yang kita dapatkan setelah dikalikan dengan M1.
WEBVTT
Jadi kita selalu harus ingat bahwa urutannya dalam beberapa
hal menjadi terbalik.
Operasi yang dilakukan
pertama adalah yang ada di sebelah kanan dan operasi yang dilakukan terakhir atau dalam kasus ini, kedua,
adalah yang ada di sebelah kiri.
Kalau kita tidak berhenti pada operasi kedua dan kita menerapkan semuanya secara
berurutan mulai dari yang pertama dan diakhiri dengan yang terakhir, yaitu Mn,
maka komposisi dari semua
operasi ini bersama-sama diberikan oleh produk
yang kamu lihat di sini,
dan kamu melihat bahwa urutannya
sekali lagi terbalik untuk alasan yang persis sama seperti sebelumnya.
Jadi singkatnya, komposisi
dari operasi probabilistik direpresentasikan oleh produk
dari matriks stokastik yang merepresentasikan mereka.
Ingat bahwa ini adalah
urutan matriks dalam produk.
Kamu akan selalu mendapatkan matriks stokastik dengan mengambil produk dari
matriks stokastik seperti ini, dan kadang kita mengekspresikan fakta ini
dengan mengatakan bahwa matriks
stokastik tertutup di bawah perkalian, dan cara kamu
bisa memikirkan ini adalah bahwa kamu tidak bisa keluar dari
himpunan matriks stokastik
dengan mengalikan mereka karena himpunan itu tertutup.
Kembali ke
urutan matriks dalam produk ini, penting untuk dicatat bahwa urutan
memang benar-benar penting.
Perkalian matriks tidak komutatif. Kalau kamu mengubah urutan
matriks dalam produk, kamu mungkin mengubah hasilnya,
dan kita tidak perlu melihat lebih jauh dari operasi deterministik
untuk melihat ini.
Berikut ini contoh sederhana dari
dua matriks stokastik, yang keduanya merepresentasikan
operasi deterministik di mana urutannya penting.
M1 merepresentasikan fungsi konstan nol. Dengan asumsi, kita membayangkan bahwa kedua operasi ini ada pada bit, sama seperti dalam contoh sebelumnya.
M2 merepresentasikan operasi not
atau bit flip.
Kalau kamu melakukan M1 terlebih dahulu
dan kemudian kamu melakukan M2, hasilnya adalah matriks ini, yang merepresentasikan
fungsi konstan satu.
Kalau kamu menyetel bit ke nol
dan kemudian kamu membaliknya, itu sama dengan hanya
menyetel bit itu ke satu.
Di sisi lain, kalau kamu melakukan M2 terlebih dahulu
dan kemudian kamu melakukan M1, ini adalah hasilnya,
dan ini masuk akal karena kalau kamu membalik bit
dan kemudian kamu menyetelnya ke nol, itu sama dengan
hanya menyetelnya ke nol.
Tidak masalah kamu sudah membaliknya. Jelas, kedua
matriks ini tidak sama, dan jadi kita punya contoh yang sangat
sederhana yang mengungkapkan
bahwa urutannya memang penting. Tentu saja, ini tidak mengejutkan sama sekali.
Kita semua tahu bahwa urutan di mana
operasi dilakukan itu penting atau setidaknya, bisa penting.
Misalnya, kalau kamu menyalakan
korek api dan kemudian kamu meniupnya, hasilnya sangat berbeda
dari meniup korek api terlebih dahulu
dan kemudian menyalakannya. Pada titik ini, kita sudah banyak bicara
tentang informasi klasik dan sekarang akhirnya saatnya untuk
membahas informasi kuantum.
Dan yang akan kita temukan adalah bahwa
secara matematis, informasi kuantum bekerja
dengan cara yang sangat mirip dengan informasi klasik
dengan beberapa perbedaan kunci.
Perbedaan kunci pertama
ada di awal, bagaimana kita mendefinisikan sebuah keadaan, dalam kasus ini, keadaan kuantum dari sebuah sistem,
dan ada rasa di mana satu pilihan ini bagaimana
kita mendefinisikan keadaan kuantum sebagian besar menentukan bagaimana
informasi kuantum bekerja.
Kita juga akan mendefinisikan bagaimana
pengukuran dan operasi bekerja, dan di pelajaran berikutnya, kita akan membahas bagaimana
informasi kuantum bekerja tidak hanya untuk sistem tunggal
tapi untuk beberapa sistem,
tapi hal-hal ini sebenarnya
mengikuti cukup alami begitu konsep keadaan kuantum dari satu sistem secara
terisolasi sudah ditetapkan.
Inilah definisinya. Keadaan kuantum dari sebuah sistem direpresentasikan oleh vektor kolom yang indeks-indeksnya ditempatkan
dalam korespondensi dengan
keadaan klasik dari sistem itu.
Jadi kita mengasumsikan di sini bahwa
sistem yang kita bicarakan punya beberapa himpunan keadaan klasik, sama seperti ketika kita berbicara
tentang informasi klasik
dan keadaan probabilistik. Entri-entri dalam vektor keadaan kuantum adalah bilangan kompleks berbeda dengan kasus probabilistik
di mana entri-entri adalah
bilangan real non-negatif.
Dan kali ini, jumlah dari nilai absolut
kuadrat dari entri-entri harus sama dengan satu berbeda dengan jumlah yang sama dengan satu
seperti yang kita miliki dalam kasus probabilistik.
Bilangan kompleks yang muncul
dalam vektor keadaan kuantum kadang disebut amplitudo dan mereka memainkan peran yang
mirip dengan probabilitas,
tapi mereka bukan probabilitas dan tidak memiliki
interpretasi yang sama.
Sekarang, saya tidak bisa memberikan kamu alasan yang baik mengapa keadaan kuantum
harus didefinisikan seperti ini selain mengatakan bahwa
para fisikawan telah menemukan
bahwa definisi ini
secara fisik relevan dan memungkinkan kita untuk mendeskripsikan dan memodelkan
sistem mekanika kuantum.
Dengan kata lain, kita memilih definisi ini
karena ini berhasil, bukan karena ada
alasan tertentu mengapa keadaan kuantum harus
didefinisikan seperti ini.
Berkenaan dengan
matematika dari konsep keadaan kuantum ini, langkah pertama untuk memahaminya dan bekerja dengannya adalah
mengingat kembali definisi ini
untuk norma Euclidean dari sebuah vektor, yang bisa kamu pikirkan secara geometris sebagai panjang dari sebuah vektor, sama seperti kamu akan memikirkan panjang
dari vektor real dua dimensi kalau kamu menggambarnya di atas selembar
kertas sebagai panah yang dimulai dari titik asal dengan cara yang biasa.
WEBVTT
Khususnya, kalau kita punya
vektor kolom v seperti ini, yang kita asumsikan punya
entri bilangan kompleks, alpha satu sampai alpha n,
maka norma Euclidean dari v didefinisikan seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Ini adalah notasi yang kita
gunakan untuk norma Euclidean dengan menempatkan garis ganda di sekitar vektor apa pun yang kita bicarakan.
Dalam kasus ini, itu adalah v, dan cara norma Euclidean didefinisikan adalah bahwa itu adalah akar kuadrat dari jumlah
dari nilai absolut kuadrat
dari entri-entri vektor.
Jadi cara lain untuk mendefinisikan apa
itu vektor keadaan kuantum adalah bahwa vektor keadaan kuantum adalah vektor kolom yang punya
entri bilangan kompleks
yang norma Euclidean-nya sama dengan satu, yang berarti bahwa ini adalah vektor satuan terhadap norma Euclidean.
Itu karena jumlah dari
nilai absolut kuadrat sama dengan satu jika dan hanya jika norma Euclidean
sama dengan satu.
Akar kuadrat tidak mengubah apa pun ketika jumlah dari nilai absolut
kuadrat sama dengan satu.
Jadi itulah apa itu vektor keadaan kuantum. Ini adalah vektor kolom dengan indeks yang sesuai dengan keadaan klasik dari sebuah sistem
yang punya entri bilangan kompleks dan norma Euclidean sama dengan satu.
Apa artinya atau apa implikasinya atau bagaimana kita harus menginterpretasikan konsep
ini adalah hal yang berbeda dan dalam beberapa hal,
studi tentang informasi
dan komputasi kuantum adalah eksplorasi dari apa
definisi ini menyiratkan, setidaknya, dalam hal
pemrosesan informasi.
Ini hanyalah titik awal.
Sebagai catatan tambahan, izinkan saya menyebutkan bahwa ada
norma-norma lain selain norma Euclidean dan notasi ini dengan garis ganda
di sekitar vektor tidak selalu
berarti norma Euclidean.
Dalam konteks yang berbeda, notasi ini bisa merujuk
ke norma yang berbeda.
Misalnya, jumlah
dari nilai absolut tanpa kuadrat atau akar
kuadrat adalah norma yang berbeda,
yang sering disebut norma satu. Sebenarnya ada cukup banyak
norma yang berbeda.
Kadang kamu akan melihat
notasi ini digunakan dengan subscript setelah
set garis kedua yang memberikan lebih banyak informasi tentang norma apa yang kita bicarakan.
Dan ketika kita melakukan itu, cukup lazim bahwa angka dua sebagai subscript
berarti norma Euclidean.
Tapi dalam seri ini, setiap kali kita punya
vektor kolom seperti ini, notasi garis ganda ini saja
berarti norma Euclidean.
Berikut ini beberapa contoh
dari vektor keadaan kuantum dan vektor keadaan kuantum tertentu ini adalah vektor keadaan qubit,
yang berarti bahwa
keadaan klasik dari sistem kita adalah nol dan satu.
Kata qubit adalah kependekan dari quantum bit, yang sebenarnya hanya sebuah bit
yang bisa berada dalam keadaan kuantum.
Dua contoh pertama sangat sederhana. Vektor basis standar
ket nol dan ket satu adalah vektor keadaan kuantum.
Keduanya adalah vektor kolom, dan indeks-indeksnya sesuai
dengan keadaan klasik nol dan satu, dan entri-entri dari vektor-vektor ini adalah bilangan kompleks.
Untuk vektor-vektor khusus ini, entri-entri-nya adalah nol dan satu, yang merupakan bilangan real, dan bahkan, mereka adalah bilangan bulat, tapi mereka juga bilangan kompleks
yang kebetulan punya
bagian imajiner sama dengan nol.
Setiap vektor punya satu entri sama dengan satu dan satu entri sama dengan nol.
Jadi ketika kita menjumlahkan nilai absolut
kuadrat dari entri-entri, kita mendapatkan satu dalam kedua kasus.
Jadi kondisi-kondisi
yang diperlukan agar vektor-vektor ini menjadi vektor keadaan kuantum terpenuhi.
Dua contoh berikutnya adalah keadaan qubit yang sangat umum ditemui yang disebut keadaan plus dan keadaan minus.
Mereka dinotasikan seperti yang
kamu lihat di sini, baik dengan ket plus
atau ket minus seperti ini, dan mereka didefinisikan seperti yang bisa kamu lihat di sini.
Sekali lagi, entri-entri dari vektor-vektor ini
adalah bilangan kompleks. Kali ini, mereka adalah plus satu dibagi akar kuadrat dua atau minus satu dibagi akar kuadrat dua,
dan ketika kita menjumlahkan
nilai absolut kuadrat, kita mendapatkan 1/2 plus 1/2, yaitu satu.
Omong-omong, meletakkan
tanda plus atau tanda minus di dalam ket seperti ini
mungkin tampak sedikit aneh karena ini bukan keadaan klasik
dari sistem kita,
tapi notasi ini tetap digunakan, dan kita akan kembali ke ini sebentar lagi.
Tapi untuk sekarang, singkatnya, kita bisa menggunakan notasi Dirac untuk menempatkan nama apa pun yang kita inginkan untuk sebuah vektor di dalam ket.
Vektor itu tidak harus
menjadi vektor basis standar ketika kita menggunakan notasi Dirac.
Berikut ini contoh keadaan qubit
terakhir untuk saat ini.
Ini adalah vektor keadaan kuantum dari sebuah qubit yang tidak punya nama khusus, dan tidak terlalu signifikan.
Entri-entri dari vektor ini adalah satu plus dua kali i
dibagi tiga dan minus 2/3.
Ini adalah bilangan kompleks, dan kalau kamu menghitung
nilai absolut kuadrat dari dua entri ini, kamu akan mendapatkan 5/9 untuk yang pertama
dan 4/9 untuk yang kedua. Jadi jumlah dari nilai absolut
kuadrat sama dengan satu.
Dan inilah satu contoh terakhir. Kali ini untuk sistem
yang keadaan klasiknya adalah empat jenis kartu.
Saya tidak tahu mengapa kita akan punya sistem yang keadaan klasiknya
adalah empat jenis kartu yang berada dalam keadaan kuantum, tapi itu mungkin secara prinsip
dan ini hanya dimaksudkan sebagai contoh.
WEBVTT
Entri-entri yang sesuai
dengan jenis yang berbeda adalah 1/2 untuk clubs, minus
i dibagi dua untuk diamonds,
nol untuk hearts karena tidak muncul dalam jumlah dan satu dibagi akar
kuadrat dua untuk spades.
Dan inilah tampilan
sebagai vektor kolom, dengan asumsi bahwa kita sudah mengurutkan
keadaan klasik seperti yang kita lakukan sebelumnya,
yaitu urutan yang
kamu lihat di sini.
Mengambil nilai absolut
kuadrat dari entri-entri ini memberikan satu perempat untuk yang pertama, juga satu perempat untuk yang berikutnya.
Nilai absolut kuadrat
dari nol sama dengan nol, jadi entri itu tidak
berkontribusi pada jumlah.
Dan akhirnya, untuk yang terakhir, kita mendapatkan 1/2. Jadi jumlahnya sama dengan satu seperti yang diperlukan agar vektor ini
menjadi vektor keadaan kuantum.
Tadi sebentar yang lalu, kita menggunakan notasi
ket plus dan ket minus untuk merujuk ke dua vektor keadaan qubit yang bukan vektor basis standar.
Dan saya ingin kembali
ke poin ini sebentar dan menjelaskan bagaimana notasi Dirac digunakan untuk vektor sembarang dan bukan hanya untuk vektor basis standar.
Seperti yang sudah saya sebutkan, kita bisa menggunakan nama apa pun yang kita
inginkan di dalam bra atau ket untuk merujuk ke sebuah vektor.
Ket adalah vektor kolom
dan bra adalah vektor baris seperti sebelumnya.
Sebagai contoh, huruf Yunani
psi sangat umum digunakan di dalam sebuah ket untuk merujuk ke beberapa vektor sembarang,
dan di sini, kita menggunakannya untuk
memberikan nama ke vektor keadaan dari sebelumnya yang tidak
punya nama khusus.
Ketika kita melakukan ini, huruf psi tidak
harus punya arti tersendiri.
Ini hanya nama dari sebuah vektor, dan ada di dalam ket untuk membantu kita memperjelas
bahwa ini adalah vektor kolom.
Ini bisa sedikit
membingungkan kadang-kadang, dan ada potensi ambiguitas kalau huruf psi bisa dikaitkan
dengan keadaan klasik dari
suatu sistem misalnya, tapi umumnya tidak
menimbulkan masalah apapun, dan kamu tidak harus menggunakan
notasi Dirac seperti ini
kalau kamu tidak mau. Menggunakan huruf kecil seperti
u, v, atau w tanpa ket juga cara yang bagus untuk
menyatakan vektor kolom
atau lebih spesifik,
vektor keadaan kuantum.
Terserah kamu notasi apa
yang kamu gunakan untuk mengekspresikan dirimu.
Kamu hanya perlu memastikan bahwa nomor satu, arti dari apa yang
kamu coba ungkapkan jelas bagi orang lain.
Dan nomor dua, bahwa kamu memahami apa yang
orang lain coba ungkapkan bahkan ketika preferensi notasi mereka tidak sama dengan milikmu.
Ada satu aturan yang sangat penting untuk menggunakan notasi Dirac
untuk vektor sembarang dan itu adalah bahwa kalau kamu punya vektor kolom
yang kamu putuskan untuk menulis
sebagai ket psi, misalnya, atau bisa berupa nama yang berbeda di dalam ket, maka vektor baris bra psi
dipahami sebagai
conjugate transpose dari vektor ket psi.
Dan di sini, ini ditulis sebagai persamaan di mana tanda dagger ini merujuk ke conjugate transpose.
Apa itu secara spesifik adalah
vektor baris yang kamu dapatkan dengan, nomor satu, mentranspos vektor, yang berarti bahwa kamu membalik
vektor ke sampingnya dan mengubahnya dari kolom menjadi baris
tanpa benar-benar mengubah entri-entri. Dan nomor dua, mengambil complex conjugate
dari setiap entri.
Kamu sebenarnya bisa melakukan
kedua operasi itu, transpose dan
complex conjugate per-entri dalam urutan mana pun atau kedua operasi itu komutatif.
Jadi untuk vektor dalam contoh ini, mengingat bahwa kita sudah memutuskan untuk
menyebut vektor ini ket psi, dipahami bahwa bra psi
berarti vektor ini
di mana kita telah mentranspos vektor dengan mengubah ket nol dan ket
satu menjadi bra nol dan bra satu, dan kita telah mengambil complex conjugate dari setiap entri,
itulah mengapa satu plus
dua kali i dibagi tiga berubah menjadi satu minus dua
kali i dibagi tiga di sini.
Inilah tampilan vektor-vektor ini ketika ditulis
secara eksplisit sebagai vektor kolom dan vektor baris.
Perhatikan, omong-omong, bahwa
aturan ini konsisten dengan notasi yang kita gunakan ketika kita punya keadaan klasik
di dalam bra dan ket.
Dalam kasus itu, entri-entri adalah
semua nol kecuali satu satu, dan jadi mengambil complex
conjugate tidak mengubah apa pun dalam kasus itu.
Kita sekarang sudah melihat bagaimana keadaan kuantum direpresentasikan sebagai vektor, tapi belum jelas pada titik ini apa makna atau implikasi-nya
dalam hal apa yang
bisa kamu lakukan dengan sistem dalam keadaan kuantum atau bagaimana kamu bisa berinteraksi dengannya.
Hal pertama yang perlu kita lakukan untuk membawa isu-isu ini ke dalam fokus
adalah membahas pengukuran.
Secara intuitif,
pengukuran memberikan mekanisme untuk mengekstrak informasi klasik
dari sistem kuantum.
Ketika kita melihat sebuah sistem
saat berada dalam keadaan kuantum, kita tidak melihat keadaan kuantum sama seperti kita tidak melihat
keadaan probabilistik,
kita melihat keadaan klasik, dan konsep pengukuran inilah yang menyediakan antarmuka.
Kalau kita, sebagai manusia, ingin mengetahui sesuatu tentang sistem kuantum, kita harus mengukurnya, dan dengan melakukannya, kita akan mengekstrak informasi klasik
tentang keadaan kuantum apa pun
yang dimiliki sistem itu.
Ada konsep
pengukuran yang berbeda. Perbedaannya memang soal
generalitas, dan kita akan mulai dengan yang paling sederhana dan paling dasar,
yang biasanya disebut
pengukuran basis standar.
WEBVTT
Kita akan menggeneralisasi ini
di pelajaran-pelajaran berikutnya. Kita akan berbicara tentang apa yang disebut pengukuran proyektif di pelajaran tiga, dan kemudian nanti di
unit ketiga dari seri,
kita akan berbicara tentang pengukuran umum, yang juga disebut positive
operator valued measures atau POVM singkatnya.
Tapi untuk sekarang, kita akan membatasi perhatian kita pada pengukuran basis standar.
Ketika pengukuran
dilakukan pada sebuah sistem, akan ada beberapa himpunan
kemungkinan hasil dari pengukuran itu, yang merupakan hasil klasik,
dan dalam kasus pengukuran basis standar, kemungkinan hasil-hasil itu adalah
tepat keadaan klasik dari sistem mana pun yang sedang diukur.
Setiap keadaan klasik itu akan menjadi hasil pengukuran dengan probabilitas tertentu, dan probabilitas itu adalah nilai absolut kuadrat
dari entri yang sesuai
dengan keadaan klasik itu dari vektor keadaan kuantum apa pun yang dimiliki sistem sesaat sebelum diukur.
Kita tahu bahwa nilai absolut kuadrat dari bilangan kompleks mana pun adalah bilangan real non-negatif, dan kita tahu dari definisi
dari vektor keadaan kuantum
bahwa jumlah dari nilai absolut
kuadrat dari entri-entri dari vektor keadaan kuantum sama dengan satu.
Jadi ini masuk akal. Setiap keadaan klasik akan muncul sebagai hasil
pengukuran dengan probabilitas tertentu dan probabilitas-probabilitas berjumlah satu.
Berikut ini beberapa contoh. Pertama, misalkan kita punya sebuah
qubit dalam keadaan plus.
Kalau kita mengukur qubit ini dengan pengukuran basis standar, kita mendapatkan nol atau
satu sebagai hasilnya.
Probabilitas mendapatkan nol adalah nilai absolut
kuadrat dari satu dibagi akar dua, yaitu 1/2, dan itu adalah probabilitas yang sama untuk mendapatkan satu.
Jadi kalau kamu mengukur keadaan plus, kamu akan mendapatkan bit acak yang seragam.
Kalau sistem berada dalam keadaan minus
bukan keadaan plus, maka pengukurannya bekerja dengan
cara yang persis sama.
Probabilitas-nya, sekali lagi, 1/2 untuk setiap kemungkinan hasil.
Satu-satunya perbedaan di sini adalah bahwa tanda plus berubah menjadi tanda minus, tapi ketika kita mengambil nilai
absolut, tidak ada yang berubah.
Kalau kita mengukur keadaan qubit ini, probabilitas untuk mendapatkan hasil nol adalah nilai absolut kuadrat dari satu plus dua kali i
dibagi tiga, yaitu 5/9,
dan probabilitas untuk mendapatkan hasil satu adalah nilai absolut kuadrat
dari minus 2/3, yaitu 4/9.
Dan akhirnya, mengukur
keadaan basis standar, ket nol memberikan hasil
nol dengan kepastian, dan demikian pula, mengukur keadaan ket satu
menghasilkan hasil satu dengan kepastian. Itu karena nilai absolut
kuadrat dari satu adalah satu.
Mirip dengan apa yang kita miliki dalam
setting probabilistik. Kita bisa mengasosiasikan keadaan kuantum ini, ket nol dalam ket satu, dengan sistem yang berada dalam
keadaan klasik itu,
dan contoh ini konsisten
dengan interpretasi itu.
Sekarang, sama seperti yang kita miliki dalam
setting probabilistik, kalau kita mengukur sebuah sistem saat
berada dalam keadaan kuantum,
maka keadaan akan berubah, secara umum, sebagai akibat dari telah
melakukan pengukuran itu.
Khususnya, dan sekali lagi, ini persis seperti yang kita miliki
dalam setting probabilistik.
Kalau kita mengukur sebuah sistem dan hasilnya adalah keadaan klasik a, maka keadaan kuantum baru
dari sistem menjadi ket a.
Jadi untuk keadaan ini
di sini, misalnya, kita melihat jenis perilaku yang sama yang kita miliki dalam setting probabilistik.
Kalau kita mengukur maka dengan probabilitas 5/9, kita mendapatkan hasil nol, dalam hal ini, keadaan
beralih ke ket nol,
dan dengan probabilitas
4/9, hasilnya adalah satu, dan keadaan beralih ke ket satu.
Kadang fenomena ini disebut sebagai keruntuhan
keadaan kuantum, dan itu adalah jenis
hal yang membuat orang
yang mempelajari fondasi
mekanika kuantum tidak bisa tidur.
Tapi dari perspektif
murni matematis, ini sebenarnya cukup sederhana
dan sangat analog dengan apa yang kita miliki dalam kasus probabilistik.
Sumber ketegangan di sini, dalam beberapa hal, menyangkut sifat fundamental dari keadaan kuantum dan apa yang mereka representasikan
dan bagaimana mereka berbeda
dari keadaan probabilistik. Tapi pada level matematis, ini mungkin adalah apa yang kamu harapkan.
Perhatikan, omong-omong, bahwa kalau
kamu mengukur kedua kalinya, maka kamu akan mendapatkan hasil yang persis
sama seperti yang kamu dapatkan pada pengukuran pertama.
Jadi ada batasan pada berapa banyak
informasi klasik yang bisa diekstrak dari keadaan kuantum, dan kita akan kembali ke poin ini segera
di pelajaran lain. Kita sudah berbicara tentang keadaan kuantum serta pengukuran, khususnya pengukuran basis standar,
yang menyediakan cara untuk
mengekstrak informasi klasik dari keadaan kuantum.
Topik yang tersisa untuk
pelajaran ini adalah operasi, khususnya operasi uniter, yang mendeskripsikan bagaimana keadaan kuantum dari sistem
bisa diubah. Secara alami, mengingat bahwa vektor keadaan kuantum berbeda dari vektor probabilitas, kamu akan mengharapkan bahwa himpunan operasi yang diizinkan
pada keadaan kuantum berbeda dari apa yang kita miliki untuk
informasi klasik, dan memang, itulah kasusnya.
Sedangkan operasi pada keadaan probabilistik direpresentasikan oleh matriks stokastik, operasi pada vektor keadaan kuantum
direpresentasikan oleh matriks uniter.
Inilah definisi dari matriks uniter.
Matriks persegi U yang punya
entri bilangan kompleks adalah uniter jika memenuhi persamaan-persamaan
yang kamu lihat di sini.
WEBVTT
Tanda dagger merepresentasikan
conjugate transpose, yang sudah kita lihat untuk vektor ketika kita berbicara tentang notasi Dirac beberapa momen yang lalu.
Di sini kita melakukan
conjugate transpose pada matriks bukan pada vektor, tapi pada dasarnya sama.
Kita mentranspos matriks, yang hanya berarti kita
menukar baris dan kolom, jadi entri JK menjadi entri KJ,
dan kita juga mengambil complex
conjugate dari setiap entri.
Juga, notasi ini
berarti matriks identitas.
Kedua persamaan ini
sebenarnya setara. Kalau kamu punya satu, maka kamu
otomatis punya yang lainnya.
Keduanya setara dengan
mengatakan bahwa U bersifat invertible, dan inversnya sama
dengan conjugate transpose.
Itu hanya berlaku untuk matriks persegi,
omong-omong. Kalau kamu punya matriks yang bukan persegi, maka salah satu dari dua
persamaan itu mungkin benar,
tapi yang satu lagi tidak akan benar.
Tapi di sini, kita berbicara
tentang matriks persegi.
Jadi ini adalah definisi standar
untuk matriks uniter, dan bagusnya karena mudah untuk memeriksa
apakah sebuah matriks uniter.
Kamu cukup mengalikan matriks ke conjugate transpose-nya dari salah satu sisi, dan kamu melihat apakah kamu mendapatkan
matriks identitas.
Ada cara setara untuk mengkarakterisasi matriks uniter, yaitu bahwa sebuah
matriks persegi bersifat uniter jika dan hanya jika tidak pernah
mengubah norma Euclidean
dari vektor mana pun ketika kamu mengalikan. Matriks N kali N U bersifat uniter jika dan hanya jika norma Euclidean dari U kali v
sama dengan norma Euclidean v untuk setiap vektor kolom n-dimensi v dengan entri bilangan kompleks.
Dan oleh karena itu, kalau v adalah
vektor keadaan kuantum, maka U kali v juga
merupakan vektor keadaan kuantum karena vektor keadaan kuantum
adalah vektor-vektor yang punya
norma Euclidean sama dengan satu.
Bahkan, kita bisa mengatakan sedikit lebih dari itu, yaitu bahwa matriks uniter adalah tepat matriks yang selalu mentransformasi vektor keadaan kuantum
menjadi vektor keadaan kuantum. Itu adalah situasi yang mirip dengan apa yang kita miliki untuk matriks stokastik
dan vektor probabilitas.
Matriks stokastik
adalah tepat matriks yang selalu mentransformasi vektor probabilitas menjadi vektor probabilitas.
Jadi setelah kita memutuskan bahwa operasi harus direpresentasikan oleh matriks, yang sama dengan mengatakan bahwa transformasi bertindak secara linear
pada vektor yang merepresentasikan keadaan, pilihan-pilihan untuk himpunan operasi yang diizinkan mengikuti secara alami, setidaknya,
secara matematis.
Sekarang mari kita lihat beberapa contoh dari operasi uniter qubit.
Kita akan melihat banyak lagi contoh
dari operasi uniter di pelajaran-pelajaran berikutnya, termasuk operasi uniter dan sistem
yang punya lebih dari dua keadaan klasik. Tapi untuk sekarang, kita akan fokus hanya
pada operasi uniter qubit.
Kita akan melihat
contoh-contoh khusus ini muncul lagi dan lagi, jadi pasti layak untuk
mengenal operasi-operasi ini.
Kumpulan contoh pertama adalah operasi Pauli yang disebut demikian.
Ini adalah operasi yang sesuai dengan matriks Pauli, yang ditunjukkan di sini.
Semuanya uniter, dan kamu bisa memverifikasi itu untuk masing-masing sesuai dengan definisi dari sebelumnya.
Matriks-matriks khusus ini
kebetulan sama dengan conjugate transpose-nya masing-masing, yang berarti bahwa semuanya
adalah matriks Hermitian.
Jadi memverifikasi bahwa semuanya
uniter, dalam kasus ini, adalah soal mengkuadratkan masing-masing dan melihat bahwa hasilnya
adalah matriks identitas.
Nama-nama yang kamu lihat untuk
matriks-matriks ini cukup standar, dan kamu juga akan melihat sigma
x, sigma y, dan sigma z disebut cukup X, Y, dan Z.
Tapi perlu diketahui bahwa huruf
kapital X, Y, dan Z juga umum digunakan untuk tujuan lain, bahkan dalam konteks
informasi kuantum,
tapi mereka adalah nama-nama yang sangat umum
untuk matriks-matriks ini.
Operasi sigma x atau X
juga disebut bit flip atau operasi not, yang sudah kita lihat
dalam konteks klasik.
Dan operasi sigma z atau Z
juga disebut phase flip.
Dan di sini, kamu bisa melihat
aksi dari operasi-operasi ini pada vektor basis standar, yang sedikit banyak menjelaskan
dari mana nama-nama ini berasal.
Tentu saja, masuk akal untuk
menyebut sigma x sebagai bit flip berdasarkan aksi ini.
Ini hanya membalik bit dari
nol ke satu atau satu ke nol.
Juga masuk akal untuk
menyebut sigma z sebagai phase flip berdasarkan aksi ini.
Tapi kalau itu belum terlalu jelas
saat ini, tidak apa-apa.
Kita akan menemui
operasi ini berulang kali dan signifikansi
dari menempatkan tanda minus di depan vektor basis ket satu
dan bukan ket nol
dan mengapa itu disebut phase flip akan lebih jelas nanti.
Contoh berikutnya adalah
operasi Hadamard, yang direpresentasikan oleh
matriks ini, yang hampir selalu diberi nama H.
Memverifikasi bahwa H bersifat uniter sekali lagi adalah
perhitungan yang mudah, yang kalau saya menyingkir, bisa kamu lihat di sini.
Mirip dengan matriks Pauli, H adalah conjugate transpose-nya sendiri.
Jadi kita punya persamaan ini, dan ketika kita melakukan perkalian, kita mendapatkan matriks identitas seperti yang diperlukan.
WEBVTT
Contoh ketiga adalah
benar-benar seluruh kelas dari operasi uniter
yang dikenal sebagai operasi phase.
Ini adalah operasi
yang direpresentasikan oleh matriks mana pun yang mengambil bentuk ini
yang kamu lihat di sini di mana theta adalah bilangan real mana pun.
Jadi entri ini
akan selalu berupa bilangan kompleks pada lingkaran satuan.
Matriks seperti ini selalu uniter, yang saya serahkan kepadamu untuk diverifikasi.
Kali ini, conjugate transpose tidak akan sama dengan matriks aslinya kecuali angka ini kebetulan
menjadi satu atau minus satu,
dalam hal ini, kita akan mendapatkan
baik matriks identitas maupun sigma z, yang sudah
kita temui sebelumnya.
Khususnya, transposisi
tidak akan mengubah apa pun pada matriks ini, tapi mengambil complex
conjugate dari setiap entri mengubah entri ini menjadi e pangkat minus i theta.
Dua operasi khusus ini adalah contoh yang sangat penting
dari operasi phase.
Untuk yang pertama, kita mengambil
theta sama dengan pi dibagi dua, dan kita mendapatkan matriks ini.
Ini umumnya disebut
operasi S atau S gate ketika kita berbicara tentang circuit, yang tidak akan kita bahas di pelajaran ini,
tapi itu adalah topik penting
yang akan datang segera.
Yang kedua adalah operasi ini. Ini adalah operasi T atau T gate.
Dan untuk ini, theta
sama dengan pi dibagi empat. Jadi ketika kita menghitung eksponensialnya, kita mendapatkan nilai ini, yaitu satu plus i dibagi
akar kuadrat dua.
Berikut ini hanya beberapa contoh singkat untuk melihat beberapa
operasi ini dalam aksi.
Inilah aksi dari
operasi Hadamard pada ket nol dan ket satu.
Kalau kita melewati
perkalian matriks-vektor, kita melihat bahwa yang kita dapatkan adalah keadaan plus dan keadaan
minus masing-masing.
Kalau kita melakukan operasi Hadamard pada keadaan plus dan keadaan
minus, di sisi lain, kita kembali ke ket nol dan ket satu.
Jadi kalau kita merapikannya sedikit, kita bisa melihat aksinya lebih jelas.
Operasi Hadamard
mentransformasi bolak-balik antara keadaan nol dan keadaan plus serta antara keadaan satu
dan keadaan minus.
Berkenaan dengan dua persamaan ini, perhatikan bahwa ini memberikan kita cara sederhana untuk mendeteksi perbedaan antara keadaan plus dan keadaan minus.
Seperti yang kita lihat sebelumnya dalam pelajaran, kalau kita mengukur keadaan plus
dan keadaan minus dengan pengukuran basis standar,
kita mendapatkan bit acak yang seragam dalam kedua kasus, yang tidak membantu kita untuk
mendeteksi perbedaannya.
Tapi kalau kita melakukan operasi Hadamard
dan kemudian kita mengukur, kita akan melihat nol jika
keadaan awal adalah keadaan plus
dan satu jika keadaan awal
adalah keadaan minus.
Jadi kedua keadaan ini memang berbeda, dan mereka bisa dibedakan
dengan sempurna dengan metode yang baru saja saya deskripsikan,
yaitu dengan pertama melakukan
operasi Hadamard dan kemudian mengukur.
Kembali ke contoh
keadaan qubit yang kita lihat sebelumnya yang tidak terlalu istimewa, kita bisa melihat apa yang dilakukan operasi Hadamard
pada keadaan tersebut
dengan mengkonversi ke bentuk
yang kamu lihat di sini dan melakukan perkalian.
Dan inilah hasilnya
yang bisa kita konversi kembali ke notasi Dirac kalau kita mau,
dan itulah satu cara untuk menghitung
aksi-aksi seperti ini.
Berikut ini contoh lain yang mengilustrasikan bahwa kamu tidak selalu
harus mengkonversi secara eksplisit ke bentuk matriks-vektor.
Kamu juga bisa melakukan
perhitungan ini secara langsung menggunakan notasi Dirac.
Contoh ini menyangkut operasi T, dan inilah ini
di sini hanya untuk referensi.
Operasi ini punya aksi ini pada keadaan basis standar.
Dan kalau kita ingin menghitung
aksi dari operasi T pada keadaan plus, misalnya, kita bisa mulai dengan mengembangkan definisi dari keadaan plus
dan kemudian menggunakan linearitas
untuk mengekspresikan hasilnya seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Kita sekarang bisa langsung memasukkan
ekspresi-ekspresi di atas ini, melakukan sedikit saja
penyederhanaan untuk suku kedua, dan kita mendapatkan hasilnya.
Kalau karena alasan apa pun kita ingin menerapkan operasi Hadamard
pada hasilnya, kita bisa melakukan hal yang serupa.
Pertama, kita mengganti ekspresi untuk T yang beraksi pada keadaan plus dan kita menggunakan linearitas seperti yang kita lakukan sebelumnya.
Dan sekarang, kalau kita mengganti
ekspresi yang sudah kita miliki untuk operasi Hadamard
yang beraksi pada ket nol dan ket satu,
kita mendapatkan ini. Dan sekarang, kita bisa mengembangkan keadaan plus dan keadaan minus untuk mendapatkan ekspresi ini,
yang bisa kita sederhanakan hanya dengan menjumlahkan, dan inilah hasil akhirnya.
Tidak ada yang terlalu
istimewa tentang contoh ini. Ini hanya dimaksudkan untuk
mengilustrasikan cara alternatif tapi setara untuk menghitung aksi
dari operasi-operasi ini. Kamu bisa menggunakan cara mana pun
yang lebih nyaman dalam situasi yang ada.
Satu poin terakhir tentang
operasi uniter adalah bahwa komposisi dari operasi uniter direpresentasikan oleh perkalian matriks
sama seperti dalam setting probabilistik, yaitu, kamu bisa menghitung aksi dari serangkaian operasi uniter
dengan cukup mengalikan
matriks-matriks bersama-sama. Dan yang akan kamu dapatkan adalah
matriks uniter tunggal yang merepresentasikan aksi gabungan
WEBVTT
dari serangkaian operasi tersebut.
Sama seperti yang kita miliki untuk matriks stokastik, matriks uniter tertutup di bawah perkalian, jadi kamu akan selalu mendapatkan matriks uniter
ketika kamu mengkomposisikan operasi uniter.
Kamu harus memastikan
kamu mengalikan matriks dalam urutan yang benar.
Tapi cara kerjanya sama seperti untuk
operasi stokastik di mana matriks untuk operasi pertama yang kamu lakukan
akan selalu muncul di sisi kanan
dari produk matriks, dan yang terakhir akan muncul
di sisi kiri.
Jadi sama seperti sebelumnya, urutannya dibalik dalam arti bahwa kamu mengkomposisikan dari kanan ke kiri bukan kiri ke kanan.
Berikut ini contoh yang menarik yang menghasilkan sebuah operasi yang dikenal sebagai operasi square root of not.
Misalkan kita pertama
menerapkan operasi Hadamard diikuti oleh operasi S, diikuti oleh operasi Hadamard lainnya.
Aksi gabungan dari
ketiga operasi ini dideskripsikan oleh produk ini.
Ini adalah operasi Hadamard pertama, ini adalah operasi S, dan ini adalah operasi Hadamard kedua.
Kalau kita melakukan perkalian matriks, yang tidak ditunjukkan di sini secara eksplisit, tapi kamu bisa melakukan ini untuk
dirimu sendiri kalau kamu mau,
hasilnya adalah matriks ini. Ini adalah matriks uniter, dan kita bisa memverifikasi itu secara langsung
atau kita bisa mempercayai fakta bahwa matriks uniter tertutup di bawah perkalian.
Harus uniter karena ketiga matriks ini uniter seperti yang sudah kita lihat.
Kita tidak punya vektor keadaan kuantum
tertentu dalam pikiran di sini.
Kita bisa membayangkan melakukan
urutan operasi ini pada vektor keadaan kuantum mana pun, dan matriks ini mendeskripsikan aksinya.
Alasan mengapa operasi gabungan ini, yaitu yang dideskripsikan
oleh matriks ini, disebut operasi square root of not,
adalah bahwa dengan melakukannya
dua kali, kita mendapatkan operasi not, atau dengan kata lain,
operasi sigma x atau X.
Melakukan operasi
dua kali direpresentasikan oleh mengkuadratkan matriks atau
mengalikannya dengan dirinya sendiri.
Dan kalau kamu melakukan ini, kamu akan melihat bahwa hasilnya
adalah matriks Pauli x.
Dan itu agak aneh, dan itu memberimu sedikit gambaran bahwa kamu bisa melakukan beberapa hal yang menarik dengan informasi kuantum yang tidak bisa kamu lakukan dengan
informasi klasik.
Tidak ada operasi klasik, yaitu yang direpresentasikan
oleh matriks stokastik yang memberikan kita operasi not
kalau kita melakukannya dua kali.
Jadi ini adalah contoh yang bagus yang mengungkapkan bahwa operasi kuantum
berperilaku sangat berbeda dari operasi klasik.
Dan itulah pelajaran satu. Di pelajaran ini, kita membahas bagaimana informasi kuantum bekerja untuk sistem tunggal secara terisolasi,
dan di pelajaran berikutnya, kita akan berbicara tentang bagaimana
informasi kuantum bekerja untuk beberapa sistem.
Terima kasih sudah menonton. Kalau kamu punya pertanyaan, silakan tinggalkan di
bagian komentar di bawah.